Okay, come and get me. Candy truth. Ooh,
a new Disney movie. I wonder what the
plot is. Oh, it's the same old story.
Alien befriends child. We've seen it
over and over with Alf, Mack, and me,
Lilo, and Stitch, Flight of the
Navigator, Iron Giant, and so many other
movies and shows. It's nothing new. It's
the same old plot. Only Ilio flips the
script. It's no longer about some
innocent encounter, but rather a child
who goes out into a field, lays on a
sigil with the words, "Aliens abduct
me," and is summoning and inviting
non-human entities to abduct him and
take him away from home. H sounds like a
great story for children. Satan has been
pushing sun worship since the beginning
of time, and now we have this kids movie
with the main protagonist being named
Ilio. The name Ilio is a masculine name
and is a revival of the Greek name for
the sun god Helios. So I don't think
it's coincidence when the main
protagonist whose name means the sun god
has one eye covered which happens to be
the Egyptian symbol of the sun god raw.
There's clearly an agenda to make the
hero the sun god who is ultimately
Satan. In the trailer, we see Ilio along
with his demonic alien friend approach
some flying cards. They're in the shape
of an oraoris. Four cards are displayed,
each with a sigil on them. A sigil in
the occult is a magical symbol used to
invoke spirits, manifest desired
outcomes, and harness energy. This is
divination. And this oraoris entity is
literally asking, "What do you want to
know? I can tell you. I contain the
secrets of the universe. He's literally
seeking divination right there in the
trailer. The synopsis is a boy named
Ilio who's misunderstood on Earth and
he's abducted by aliens and accidentally
becomes Earth's ambassador to the
galaxy. Unlike past protagonists, Ilio
actively seeks contact, crafting a
ritual display with a giant sigil and a
plea, "Aliens, abduct me." Huh? You
okay? I'm trying to get abducted by
aliens. And the trailer's full of
symbols from the occult sigil to the
oneeyed symbolism and the alien gray
right there on his t-shirt. And when the
aliens come to abduct him, his reaction
is excitement and glee. It's really
happening.
This is literally grooming children into
the new age and teaching them how to
summon nonhuman entities, which are
literally demonic beings. This isn't
just harmless entertainment. This is
occult propaganda. Newagers for years
have been going out to fields and
meditating and asking to see the alien
beings. And next thing you know, a UFO
or an orb comes by. And even Alistister
Crowley, the self-professed most
wickedest man alive, would often have
encounters with a being that he said was
a demonic being. And it looked just like
these alien grays that people are seeing
today. 2 Corinthians 11:14 says, "And no
marvel, for Satan himself is transformed
into an angel of light." Satan isn't
coming as some red man with goat legs,
horns, and a pitchfork. He appears as an
angel of light bringing knowledge. And
this is how so many people have been
sucked into worshiping him in one form
or another. Alien worship isn't anything
new. It's just rebranded paganism. In
ancient times, pagans looked to the
stars and worshiped beings they believed
came from the heavens, gods of fire,
sky, and light. The Samrians called them
the Anunnaki, powerful sky beings who
descended to teach man knowledge and
rule over them. Hm. Think about the
Garden of Eden and a being that
descended from the heavens and appeared
as a talking reptile to bring knowledge.
The Egyptians had Thoth, a feathered
being who brought writing and wisdom.
The minds had Kukon, the serpent god
from the stars. In every ancient
culture, we see the same common pattern,
reptilian, shining, or winged gods
descending from the sky. But the Bible
warned us. Deuteronomy 32:17 says, "They
sacrificed unto devils, not to God, to
gods whom they knew not." These gods
that weren't Yahweh, that they didn't
know, were literally just Satan in
disguise. He's not original. He's a
deceiver that changes costumes each
generation. In the Garden of Eden, he
was a serpent. To the Samarans, he was
the Anunnaki. And to our generation,
it's the alien grays. And because of pop
culture propaganda, we see these demonic
entities as cute, fun, trendy, and cool.
But the goal is the same. To divert your
worship from the one true god who
deserves it to Satan himself by any
means necessary. When a child in a
Disney Pixar movie lies down inside a
giant sigil calling on extraterrestrials
smiling, it's not just an artistic
choice, it's spiritual conditioning. So
these alien befriending children plots
have always been suspicious. But Elio
boldly removes the veil and teaches
children to seek their own abduction.
Writer Amy Title explains the process is
part of a new trend in UFO circles
called C5.
C5 is a UFO summoning group. The people
who are involved with C5 use a special
app, certain frequencies, and meditation
to try to summon UFOs so they can see
them. So before you take your family to
the theater or stream Elio, think about
what the message is to your children.
That summoning entities is safe and fun.
That aliens are just misunderstood
friends. That Earth is boring and other
realms are your true destiny. that
parents are clueless and that other
worldly beings, they're the ones who get
you. You need to make friends. I just
want to belong somewhere. So, if any
aliens are listening, please come and
get me. Okay, bye. I love you. Back
home, I didn't fit in. I thought Earth
was the problem. But what if it's me?
Well, I like you and you seem fine to
me. That's not innocent storytelling.
That's programming. In biblical terms,
it's spiritual warfare disguised as
entertainment. If this video was eye-
openening to you, please click the
thumbs up. It really helps this video
get into the algorithm. If you're new to
this channel, please click subscribe and
the bell so that you don't miss a single
video. And please share this with your
family and friends. And we'll see you
next time on Candid Truth. Candid Truth.
[Music]